zum start des impfens in den
hausarztpraxen sprechen wir doch mit dem
chef des hausärzteverbandes ulrich
weigeldt schönen guten tag erweitert
unter geworden herr waigel schlägt jetzt
die große stunde der hausärzte naja die
schlägt schon die ganze zeit weil
öffentlich vergessen der kollege hat
gesagt was wir an beratungsbedarf haben
mit dem hin und her was wir alle leute
beschäftigt haben sind wir schon die
ganze zeit gut ausgelastet aber wir
wollen jetzt und es hat der kollege sehr
deutlich gemacht wir wollen jetzt
wirklich meter machen wir wollen jetzt
zusehen dass wir in dem impfen
vorankommen und deswegen brauchen wir da
viel impfstoff aber sie kriegen das auch
hin und sieht ja dass wir es hinkriegen
und unsere patienten wollen ist auch so
wir sind darauf vorbereitet weil wir
eigentlich schon viel länger gesagt
haben wir müssen für unsere patienten da
sein die auch zu uns kommen wollen und
gerade den ländlichen bereichen es ist
nicht einzusehen dass man 40 kilometer
fährt wenn die hausärzte nebenan wohnt
da kommen wir noch mal auf die zahlen
herr weigelt sie bekommen jetzt diese
woche 940.000 impfdosen das sind bei den
35.000 hausarztpraxen die sich
angemeldet haben circa knapp 27
impfdosen pro praxis ende des monats
sollen es dreimal so viele sein also
dann knapp 3 millionen impfdosen pro
woche wie viele könnten die hausärzte
pro woche
denn aus ihrer sicht verhelfen also das
ist relativ viel weil wir haben ja pilot
praxen die bereits seit märz oder anfang
märz impfen und die erfahrungen dort
sind dass es ohne weiteres möglich ist
60 70 80 oder 100 patienten in der woche
impfen zu können
das hängt natürlich immer ein bisschen
von der praxis ab von der größe von
organisation und und was uns sehr
wichtig ist wir müssen diese bürokratie
die das begleitet unter schrauben
diese impfung gegen kobe 19 muss eine
impfung werden wie jede andere auch es
wird geimpft das wird dokumentiert aber
es werden die 910 seiten papier
ausgefüllt
die kassenärztliche vereinigung die hat
im jahr 2019 etwa 55.000 hausärzte
registrierter fehlen also noch so knapp
20.000 von den 35
die sich bisher registriert haben jetzt
fürs impfen kommen diese 20.000 noch aus
ihrer sicht oder was mt das ist eine
frage die gar nicht so einfach zu
beantworten ist ich glaube dass die
kolleginnen und kollegen die nur bis in
zürich sind sehen dass es funktioniert
und dann werden sie auch einsteigen aber
es gibt halt auch viele die zwar ein
hausarzt sitz haben an der zulassung
aber etwas anderes machen und die werden
natürlich auch vielleicht bei der
impfung dann fehlen und insofern ist es
so ein bisschen immer die frage stimmen
die zahlen alle so aus als sitzt kann
auch von onkologen besetzt ja das heißt
halt noch mal fest für uns beide also
diese drei millionen dosen pro woche die
also ende des monats dann da sein sollen
für die hausarztpraxen die reichen aus
ihrer sicht auch nein also ich glaube
dass wir tatsächlich so viel brauchen
dass wir tatsächlich diese im kapazität
ausschöpfen können von 60 bis 100
patienten pro praxis dass nicht so viele
dann also vier bis fünf millionen pro
woche ja etwa glaube ich schon dass das
ungefähr hinkommt und mal unser ziel ist
und das ist glaube ich deutlich geworden
auch in dem interview mit den kollegen
unser ziel ist möglichst viele menschen
möglichst schnell zu impfen
deswegen sind patienten ja auch schon
angerufen worden in der letzten woche so
dass alle jetzt auch bereit stehen und
wir nicht irgendwelche impfdosen am
schluss übrig haben impfdosen übrig
haben dessen gutes stichwort der
generalsekretär der deutschen
gesellschaft für immunologie der hat
gestern gefordert keine impfdosen mehr
für zweit impfungen zurückzulegen der
zeit meinte er
legen etwa 1,7 millionen dosen auf halde
sind sie auch dafür jetzt einfach alles
zu verkämpfen
ich glaube das ist ein richtiger weg ist
möglichst alles zu verhelfen das muss
man so ein bisschen gucken leute die
jetzt früh geboren sind und den nächsten
zwei wochen die zweitimpfung brauchen da
würde ich mal sagen das sollte man
berücksichtigen
ansonsten sollte man es ruhig
auseinander ziehen und die zweitimpfung
dann machen wenn der nächste impfstoff
welle dann kommt ich glaube dass die
industrie das liefern kann
vielleicht eins zu sagen wenn man jetzt
sagt nach dem zweiten peaks erst gibt es
eine gibt es eine erleichterung wenn
auch schon der erste vielleicht
großen impfschutz führt kann das
natürlich wieder zu diskussionen führen
dass man diese im zweiten dann in der
distanz verkürzen möchte deswegen muss
man mit solchen äußerungen glaube ich
ziemlich vorsichtig sein wofür werden
sie denn dann würden sie sagen es geht
aber vor dass wir lieber mehr menschen
den ersten für die erste impfung geben
als dass weniger menschen eben nach der
zweiten impfung eben freiheiten haben
also ich glaube ehrlich gesagt dass man
das noch mal vielleicht bis unabhängig
untersuchen sollte dann wir wissen dass
die impfstoffe der unterschiedlich sind
und bei manchen ist es so dass
tatsächlich schon nach der ersten
impfung nach drei wochen sich ein
solcher schutz aufgebaut hat dass man
darüber schon nachdenken kann ob das
nicht schon mal reicht fürs erste wenn
man das gegebenenfalls mit tests
kombiniert letztes thema in unserem
gespräch sie haben sich am wochenende in
der rheinischen post auch für
abweichungen von der imf reihenfolge
ausgesprochen wie sehr denn abweichen
davon
ja das ist eine gute diskussion also ob
wir wirklich abweichen wenn man sich
anguckt was der ethikrat sich überlegt
hat geht es in der obersten altersgruppe
80plus natürlich in eine ganz
entscheidende priorität das waren die
menschen mit dem höchsten risiko zu
erkranken oder auch an der krankheit zu
versterben
insofern ist das ganz wichtig gewesen
die nachgeordnete reihenfolge kann nicht
nur sich nach dem alter richten sondern
hier müssen wir mit einbeziehen welche
vorerkrankungen es gibt sie haben eine
patientin gezeigt die eine
herztransplantation hat ja das heißt sie
geschichten müssen berücksichtigt werden
und werden von uns natürlich auch
berücksichtigt und wir machen das nicht
sozusagen und pi mal daumen viermal auch
wenn wir weiter beobachten wo sich
waigel chef des hausärzteverbandes jeden
tagesgespräch bei phoenix vielen dank
ereignet vielen dank in der bauer